so I'm you go like this
[Music]
No
Oh dark car
gorgeous you see didn't replace your
large small adjustment
[Music]
even if you like excuse me you have a
drop
Oh
all the center move all stay here as
this hand opens move away
hey inside keep on the outside right
very sorry
that's it that's all I need I don't need
this big thing this hand oh okay just
open it up keep anything don't do the
head
[Music]
so
you see come on once I have until boom
[Music]
ha
when you're doing but when I start on
here but you see I'm gonna move you see
oh we get up like no Brad no crap just
the right friction so what's happening
here is you only have extra boys
speaking to you the same time you get up
and say so you can just do it externally
Oh
[Music]
this a they're not about and use this
things that people okay you don't live
like this you don't pull it all the
Valentine okay go back to cutting of
humming don't let it stop moving hey my
job is to reconcile the energy whoa I'm
inside his permit all right but just
he's inside my move so I'm not gonna go
in here right and then all right I'm
gonna dive inside this you're fine he's
right there we're coming back okay
you're gonna top that Bergquist a victor
you see this time he's gonna dive
outside okay watch my don't move but I'm
gonna go inside this time
[Music]
there is a push down so when you do the
bid you see I moved it forward right my
goal is not to twist his arm when to
quit wait I'm not high so I'm here okay
[Music]
so what do you only do we not learning
it there's nothing here
you just you took the ping up a million
times in half because they want the hot
behind the BOP we know the guy
[Music]
so some of these are really trying hard
used to know if we ever go down right we
do sometimes we come this way but the
attacking loved what now okay that might
be why you let the arm that okay but if
you're doing kilo awesome some fuel leak
your comment